foreign
good morning thank you so much for your
interest and uh
for us as Epp group the largest
political family in the European
Parliament it's great to be in splits we
are discussing uh yesterday and today
the ideas for the next upcoming nine
months that is a preparatory phase
towards the European elections next year
our continent will decide about the
future and we as the biggest party in
Europe we want to offer to the citizens
a convincing approach for how to manage
the next years in front of us to create
safety to create also protecting Europe
for their daily life and that's why we
care first of all about the very
concrete issues on the table
for example inflation living costs
housing is close to our citizens we try
also on European level to assist the
national level together to solve these
questions we have as a second top
priority the migration debate on our
desk where we must reduce the numbers
the numbers are too high and the state
must decide who is coming and not the
Smugglers are deciding and to combine
this also with a humanitarian approach
that we are committed to also help our
Korean friends those who are as refugees
here in Europe so to find a good balance
on this and the third point is for us
the future perspective for Europe the
European people's party we are the
Christian democrats we are the founding
party of today's European Union ordinary
Schumann made today's Europe possible
and our idea is now to offer also for
the next year's convincing plan how to
strengthen the today's
to continue our path and for all these
debates it's great to be in Croatia
because Croatia is a perfect country for
discussing these issues I want to thank
Andre blinkowicz the prime minister of
Croatia for his clear commitment for his
leadership Croatia is a place where we
can see that we can convince people in
favor of a pro-european approach with
the Schengen enlargement we see Euro
joining the Eurozone approach that you
can win the support of citizens for
doing so and this Spirit of Croatia this
Spirit of HD set here in Croatia is a
motivation for us on European level and
it shows also that partnership National
strong politicians and European embedded
approach especially having Andre
blenkovich as as prime minister in mind
that he is well connected knows a lot of
friends on the European level that is
benefiting the Croatia and also Europe
is benefiting out of this that's why
it's great to be in Croatia
uh thank you very much dear Manfred
again welcome but this time welcome also
to Ursula from The Line president of the
European commission and really an honor
for each desserts to be the host of the
final study days of the Epp group before
the next European elections in June
2024. this has been indeed uh almost the
month of the constant Epp activity in
Croatia last weekend in Zagreb we had
the youth Epp Council now the study day
is here with the highest leaders of the
EU institutions and few weeks our
friends from the Epp from the committee
of the regions will be also gathering in
Croatia that is a signal of respect of
our party friends across Europe and also
an opportunity to discuss our
achievements to discuss the current
context and most of all to see what are
the solutions for Europe in the future
as much has outlined there are several
key important political points and
principles that we stand for as the
founding party of the European project
it is of course important that our main
values and that is the values of the
Christian Democratic parties
people's parties also part of the
liberal thought but also the heritage of
the Judo Christian civilization are put
in place also in the policies before the
elections of next year there are some
main concerns at the agenda of all of
the European countries today the first
one of course the security security
stemming from multiple crises one our
way of life that was impacted by the
covid-19 pandemic for almost two years
intensively then the impact of Russia's
aggression against Ukraine and then the
third threat and that is the threat of
the illegal migrations and that puts the
issues of security in the focus and the
policies that we are discussing here
should in our view be the main line of
the policies of Europe as a whole in the
next five years period the other issue
is competitiveness of European economy
given the big Global changes and the
impact on the economies and finances of
all of these crises we need to
strengthen the joint solidarity in the
times of Crisis I think we have managed
excellently and my praise goes to Ursula
and the initiatives that the mission has
taken I have many times said that kovid
was a big problem but European Union
came up with a big answer through the EU
Next Generation in Croatia having at our
disposal more than 10 billion euros
above the usual multi-annual Financial
framework funds gives us a chance to
boost our economy to set good Targets on
the critical infrastructural Investments
but also to help us in keeping the
social cohesion something that was a top
priority for my government because I
always said we will remain United and
supportive to Ukraine as long as we
manage to avoid the social fraction and
keep the social peace in our own
countries and this is what we have
attained so far the third point I'd like
to make is a little bit looking ahead in
terms of the perspective of the
countries that are in our neighborhood
in the enlargement process for us as a
neighboring country to Southeast Europe
we have a lot of expertise a lot of
knowledge about the trends in our
neighborhood we are now expecting the
new commission's report on the progress
and we also think that all of our
neighbors should actually accelerate
their reform process in order to be more
ready to enter the next stages of the EU
succession process this goes also for
the efforts being done by Ukraine and
Moldova in particular and of course I
think that a final point is how the Epp
as the sober mainstream party should
find answers for fighting demagogues I
wouldn't even call them the populace but
demagogues across the political Spectrum
we all have them whether they're in
Croatia or in other European country is
with arguments they're always using
every single potential not even a crisis
but let's say it's a topic to attack the
governments from the angle that they
believe is useful for them but at the
same time never ever offering any
solution to any real problem that the
citizens or the economy is needing and
that's why the campaigns are the moment
when everybody should come clearly up
front and stand for the values and
actions that will be taken in the future
I will always remember this combined
Mandate of the European Parliament where
Manfred and the whole group gave us a
big support and of course commission led
by Ursula as the days when Croatia
joined Schengen area when Croatia joined
Eurozone when we entered European
stability mechanism when we agreed due
to the objective circumstances to extend
the deadline of the use of the EU
solidarity fund and thank you Ursula for
for understanding and of course having
positioned ourselves now as 10 years
member of the European Union as a
reliable and a solid partner and all of
that is always easier and more efficient
being a member of the European people's
party thank you for coming to split
yeah thank you very much dear Manfred
dear Andre indeed I will also always
remember the first of January of this
year where I had the honor and the
pleasure to be in Zagreb and to
celebrate with you the integration in
Schengen and the Euro and it was amazing
and heartwarming to see the pride of
this country
to join Schengen and the Eurozone and
therefore I mean Croatia is a European
success story and it's your leadership
that brought Croatia exactly to that
point and Manfred I also want to thank
you
for the last four years we have together
navigated through manifold crisis
started indeed with a global pandemic an
economic crisis and then the brutal war
that Russia Unleashed against Ukraine at
the same time we have together agreed
and worked through one of the most
ambitious legislative agendas of the
European Union since its beginning so
many thanks for your leadership and your
clear guidance on and orientation and
the good work we've done together
in nine months now
there will be European elections so the
study days are very good to take stock
but also to look forward to take the
opportunity to reflect on what we've
done in the last four years but also to
set the priorities for the future
Russia's war against Ukraine has proven
that there is a strong need for Europe
to adapt to a more dangerous and
volatile geostrategic and geopolitical
environment we have stepped up our
efforts towards the defense Union and
strengthened our ties with trusted
Global Partners but also with NATO
allies all of this while supporting
Ukraine financially and with military
support and humanitarian Aid in a sum of
by now 81 billion euros
we've seen Russia's strong blackmail on
energy that has strained our Energy
System but thanks to a very determined
and United answer we've gotten largely
writ of our dependency of Russian fossil
fuels
Energy prices that were skyrocketing
last year and summer have come back to
pre-war levels
but we know that they remain
structurally high so this is one of the
topics we will discuss when we look at
competitiveness in the global in the
international scene a key solution to
that is to engage and to improve the
clean Technologies because this
increases our independence it is good
paying jobs here it's homegrown energy
it reinforces our competitiveness and
strengthened our sovereignty
another challenge we must face is
irregular migration
the latest events in lampedusa show the
need to fix our assignment migration
system and thanks also to Epp we have
made good progress and I thank you for
that Manfred and your leadership in
adopting proposals that are core to The
Pact of migration and Asylum
I strongly urge now the member states to
find agreement on the crisis regulation
in the meeting of the ministers for home
Affairs today we must now finish the job
we must ensure proper implementation of
the migration and Asylum back then in
the European union we need these common
rules
and let me stress this
our citizens rightly so expect that it
is Europe that will decide who comes to
us and under what circumstances and not
the traffickers and Smugglers as Epp we
know organized crime and these other
traffickers and Smugglers must be fought
finally enlargement is indeed we all
three mentioned it's a topic that is
very close to our heart
the past enlargement has been a great
success for countries such as Croatia
and the great benefit for the European
Union so we must replicate this with the
current candidate countries of course
it's a merits-based process
but this requires simultaneously
structural reforms in the candidate
countries and a parallel track of Reform
on the side of the European Union it is
very important that we explain to Our
member states and to our citizens that
in the new geostrategic environment
an enlargement
merits-based is strengthening us and is
necessary and beneficial for us so this
is a view on the discussions we will
have today many thanks again for the
invitation it's good to be back in
Croatia and it's good to be together
here with our Epp thank you let's go to
work
foreign